زياره الرئيس السنين شيت جيم بينك شهدت
ابتعاده عن الفنادق الفاخره المحيطه
بالميدان الاحمر في موسكو واختياره جناحا
رئاسيا في فندق المملوك للصين يقع فندق
سولوكس داخل مركز اعمال صينيا ضخم بمساحه
12 فدانا وافتتح العمل الماضي بعد تغيير
الملكيه وتعتبر بل تعتبر دولتان الفندقان
تجسيدا للعلاقات الصينيه الروسيه التي
طوطت بشكل كبير منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا وسائل اعلام روسيه اشارت الى ان
سلسله شركه سوليوكس الصينيه اصبحت مالكه
الفندق بعد خروج مجموعه انتركو من روسيا
الى جانب العديد من الشركات الاخرى
المملوكه للغرب الجناح الرئاسي لتشيم مكون
من سبع غرف ويقع في الطابق العشرين وتبلغ
مساحته 4000 قدم مربع وادى وجود الرئيس
الصيني في المنطقه لاغلاق عده طرق حيويه
تربط موسكو بضواحيها الشماليه الشرقيه حيث
يقع الفندق